là nous avons sorti
la sainte machine de ravitaillement du siècle se tenait et
inculpé pour une attaque sandre debout
et coupe la musique que je composerai sous ça
parce que nous n'aurons pas d'ennuis
Mais
contre-offensive repose en partie
c'est sur ces données que l'on sait où aller
où les régiments d'état-major où quels étaient les autres
articles de l'armée que nous connaissons et que nous expérimentons souvent
changer de toute façon je sais
sans information aux paroisses des militants nous
Exprimer le motif de la télé est allumé
agu territoires complets vuitton et les deux
nous sommes tous les deux heureux de ne pas nous soutenir les mains
ruf confirmation par le mappeur à la fois
confirmation de leur importance pour le défilé russe
émotions et effets
Pas